The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to this
lecture on nonlinear finite
element analysis of solids and
structures.
In this lecture, I would like
to continue to consider the
plate with a hole that we
already considered in the
previous lecture.
But I now would like to
turn our attention
to a nonlinear solution.
As we mentioned in previous
lectures, a nonlinear analysis
should only be performed only
once a linear solution has
been obtained.
The linear solution checks the
finite element model and
yields valuable insight
into what
nonlinearities are important.
And once again, we considered
the linear solution of this
plate in the previous lecture.
We now want to go on with
the nonlinear solution.
Here we have the plate with
the hole once again.
It's a square plate subjected
to the loading shown.
Here is the whole.
These were the material
data that we used
in the linear analysis.
The thickness of the plate
is given here.
We consider only one quarter
of the plate because of
symmetry conditions, we can
considering that one quarter,
analyze the whole plate,
as we have discussed in
the previous lecture.
In the previous lecture, we
also showed how we use
ADINA-IN to generate the
data for this mesh.
And this input data then is
used in ADINA to actually
perform the analysis.
We did the analysis for
linear conditions in
the previous lecture.
Some important considerations
for the nonlinear analysis are
now what material model to
select, what displacement
strain assumptions to make,
what sequence of load
application to choose, and
what nonlinear equation
solution strategy and
convergence criteria to select.
We will address these issues
in this lecture.
We use, once again,
the ADINA system.
Now, of course, for the
elasto-plastic static response.
We will also investigate the
effect on the response when a
shaft is placed into
the plate hole.
Some important observations
regarding the nonlinear
analysis are given on
this viewgraph.
First of all, we notice that
the recommendations that we
discussed regarding the linear
analysis that we discussed in
the previous lecture are also
very valid here of course.
But for the nonlinear analysis,
we need also to
consider and be careful with the
sequence and incremental
magnitudes of load application
and the choice of convergence
tolerances.
We ill address, of course,
these issues just now.
The first analysis that I'd like
to discuss with you is a
limit load calculation
of the plate.
Here we show the plate and the
load, p, will increase
continuously up to a maximum
value and then decrease to 0.
The plate is modelled as an
elasto-plastic material.
And the material assumption
is summarized on
this viewgraph here.
Here are the material
properties.
We assume basically
it is a steel.
Notice the stress strain
law is shown here.
We assume isotropic hardening
in the analysis.
We discussed what this means
in an earlier lecture.
The initial Young's modulus is
the one that we use for the
linear analysis.
Nu is equal to 0.3.
And the strain hardening
modulus is given here.
This idealization is probably
only applicable to small
strain conditions,
strains that are
smaller than 2% roughly.
The maximum that you would want
to allow is probably 4%.
And we will actually perform
the analysis first using a
materially nonlinear
only formulation.
This means, as we discussed in
the early lectures, that we
neglect all kinematic
nonlinearities, that we only
include the material
nonlinearities in the
analysis, these material
nonlinearities.
Later on, we however want to
also perform in this lecture
an analysis that includes the
displacement large quotations
and in fact even large
strain conditions.
And we will study those analysis
results in comparison
to the material nonlinear
only analysis results.
The load history used
for the analysis is
shown on this viewgraph.
You can see that we are
increasingly linearly the load
up to a maximum value of 650
MPa, megapascals, and then
suddenly decrease
the load to 0.
Notice we are using altogether
14 steps, 13 to increase the
load and just one step
to decrease the load.
Of course, we are having
here a time axis.
But the load step or time
step that we used was
delta t equal to 1.
Well we performed this analysis
a few weeks ago in my
laboratory at MIT.
And we brought in a video crew
to video record our actions.
I'd like to now share with you
what we have recorded and also
narrate to you what actually is
happening in the computer
run as we prepare the computer
run, as we run it, and also
interprets the resides.
Our first step is to modify
the input data that we
prepared in the previous
lecture for the linear
analysis of the plate.
We now have to, of course,
modify this input data.
First of all, to introduce the
load curve, this load history
curve that we just discussed.
And then we also have to modify
the material data to
correspond to the elasto-plastic
material data
that we now want to associate
with a plate.
So let us look now at the video
record of what we did
some weeks ago in my laboratory
at MIT regarding
the change of these
input data.
Here we see once more the
mesh that we're using
to analyze the plate.
And now we prepare input
data for ADINA-IN.
Here we input the time function
that we employ.
You recognize the function
points for time 0, 13, and 14
with the values 0, 6.5, 0.
We also input that 14 steps are
used in the analysis, that
time step delta t is 1.
Next we input the material
definition.
And note that there is a
typographical error.
We typed plestic instead
of plastic.
We try to do the typing fast and
did not notice the error.
Notice the Young's module E,
Poisson's ratio nu, the strain
hardening modulus ET, and the
yield stress [? sigma ?]
yield are defined.
Because of the typographical
error, the program prints out
an error message, namely the
plestic material is not found
in the library.
Here we see the library
of material models
available in ADINA.
The library consists of the
material models elastic,
orthotropic, thermo-elastic,
and so on and so on.
We know retype the material
data definition.
We also do not want to use
equilibrium iterations.
The default in ADINA is to use
Actually, the BFGS method we
discussed earlier because
large errors of solution
can accumulate when
iterations are not used.
We discussed all of
this earlier.
Let's see what happens when we
do not iterate in the solution
of this problem, just
as a point of study.
We now finally by the command
ADINA generate
the ADINA data input.
Note that in this input
preparation we only change the
data from the linear analysis
data used in the previous
lecture to the data for the
nonlinear analysis we want to
perform now.
Having set up the proper input
data for ADINA-IN and having
used ADINA-IN to generate the
input data for ADINA, we can
now execute that input data with
ADINA obtain our first
analysis results.
We evaluate these analysis
results by plotting the force
applied here as a function
of the displacements
corresponding to this
motion as well.
And we will see that the force
displacement curve looks
rather unphysical.
In other words, the
results don't make
much physical sense.
So we search for
an explanation.
Why is that so?
And we will find that the reason
is that we did not use
equilibrium iterations
in the analysis.
In fact, if you go back, you
will see that we deliberately
did not want to use equilibrium
iterations in this
first analysis, although in
ADINA the default is to use
equipment directions.
But I wanted to once show you
what kind of results you must
expect if you don't use
equilibrium iterations.
So we realized that we should
really use equilibrium
iterations and that we will, of
course, have to change our
input a little bit through
ADINA-IN in order to perform
equilibrium iterations.
The load history that we will
still be using is the same.
Here it is shown once again.
But now we will use the default
method of equilibrium
iterations, the BFGS method.
And this one will be applied,
this method of equilibrium
iteration will be used
for each load step.
Once again, 13 load steps up
and one load step down.
The convergence criteria that
we using in the analysis are
show here, the convergence
criteria on energy.
And we talked about this one
quite extensively in a
previous lecture.
And the convergence criteria on
the force, again, I'd like
to refer you to our
previous lecture.
When we apply equilibrium
iterations in each step, we
will see that our results
look good.
They make physical sense.
In fact, they look
quite appealing.
So let us look now at these
solution results.
Let us go, in other words, to
what has happened in the
laboratory the way we
have been video
recording it earlier.
Here we see the solution
results, the load applied as a
function of the displacement,
the extension
of the quarter plate.
On the horizontal axis, we
measure the displacement.
On the vertical axis, we
measures of value of the load,
actually the pressure applied.
So far the curve looks OK.
But we show here only the
responsible for the first 13
steps for which the load has
increased monotonically.
here we see now the
load displacement
response for all 14 steps.
Notice that the scale on the
horizontal axis measuring
displacement is different from
what we used before.
Note that the 13 first steps
bring us to the maximum load
and maximum positive
displacement and that the
predicted unloading response
in step 14 is quite
unrealistic.
We obtain a large negative
displacement.
As we will see, this is due to
not having used equilibrium
iterations.
Next, we look at the mesh and
study the plastic zones as
they develop with
increasing load.
A time code is given
about the mesh.
This time code gives
the step number.
It increases until time
is equal to 14.
The plastic zones are
shown by shading the
area that is plastic.
For the first steps, there's
no plasticity.
Then the plastic zone is small,
it develops around the
hole and it grows rapidly
as the larger
load levels are reached.
Note also how the plastic zone
spreads through the elements.
We used 3 by 3 Gauss numerical
integration and test whether
an integration point
has gone plastic.
If so, we shade the contributory
area of the
integration point.
As an average for each
integration point, the
contributory area is 1/9 ninth
of the element area.
Here at step 12, you can very
nicely see how the plastic
zones have progressed through
the elements.
The elastic plastic
interface boundary
goes through the elements.
Note that at step 14, after
unloading much off the plate
is still plastic.
This is quite unphysical.
We now rerun the analysis with
equilibrium iterations and
here is the load displacement
response we now obtain.
First we look at the
scales on the axes.
We note that the loading
response is similar to what we
had before.
Although a much larger
displacement is
reached in steps 13.
The unloading response in step
14 is now quite realistic,
with a permanent positive
displacement at zero load.
Finally, we show the plastic
zones for this analysis.
Note that we show the initial
mesh time 0 and then
immediately the time
equals 6 results.
Initially, the plasticity
progresses as much as in the
analysis without equilibrium
iterations, but the final
spread of plasticity reached
in step 13 is larger.
And after unloading of the
load at the end of the
analysis, the complete
plate is elastic.
However, clearly permanent
deformations have occurred as
can be seen by looking at the
default mesh at time 14.
As we discussed already, our
analysis results now look
quite good.
They look quite reasonable.
But one additional way to
evaluate the analysis results
is to plot stress vectors.
We did so in the linear analysis
of the previous
lecture when we also looked at
the analysis results obtained
from this mesh, but of course,
in linear analysis.
We want to do now the same for
the nonlinear analysis results
that we obtained.
And let us just quickly look
at what we're doing in the
stress vector output.
We plot at each integration
point two lines as shown here.
If they are carrying an arrow,
then it is tensile stress.
No arrow means compressive
stress.
And notice these two
lines correspond to
the principal stresses.
Notice that the lengths of these
lines are proportional
to the magnitudes
of the stresses.
So let's now do a stress vector
plot for the mesh at
time 13 and at time 14, in other
words, at maximum load
application and after removal
of the total load, four the
results that we just
have obtained.
Here we see the stress vectors
plotted onto the total mesh
for the stress state at time
13, that is at total load.
We note of course, that there
is very much information,
there are many stress vectors.
To see any detail we have to
focus our attention onto
certain elements.
Here we now look closer at the
elements adjacent to the
horizontal symmetry line.
We note that the stress vectors
correspond to vertical
tensile stresses as expected.
At a top edge of the plate we
see tensile vertical stresses
and tensile horizontal
stresses.
The maximum stress at any
integration point is 1100
megapascals and occurs
near the hole.
Here we now see the stress
vector plot at time 14, that
is after load removal.
It is most interesting
to study the
stress flow in the mesh.
Note that the stresses flow
along and parallel to the free
surface of the plate.
This must be so because there
are no externally applied
tractions anymore.
Here we see the detail of
the stress flow in the
corner of the plate.
The stress vectors are parallel
to the free surface.
And here is the stress flow in
the elements around the hole.
The same observations apply.
The maximum stress is
880.3 megapascals.
This completes what I wanted to
show you in this phase of
the analysis.
This completes our materially
nonlinear only
analysis of the plate.
However, if we look at the
solution results once more
closely, we find that in this
element here the magnitude of
the strains is about 2% at the
end of load step 11, 4% at the
end of load step 12, and
14% to 15% at the end
of load step 13.
In other words, at maximum
load application, we have
certainly here large strains.
And one might very well ask,
what is the effect of this
large strain on the
analysis results?
Of course, in the materially
nonlinear only solution, we
did not include any kinematic
nonlinearities.
So our next objective is then to
perform analysis that said
include kinematic
nonlinearities.
And we want to now proceed
with a total Lagrangian
formulation analysis, which
includes large displacements,
large rotations, but
only small strains.
And I also want to share with
you some solution results that
we obtained using an updated
Lagrangian formulation.
We did not talk about
this formulation
in the earlier lectures.
We did talk about this
formulation, but not about
that formulation.
This formulation really
is best covered
in a separate lecture.
However, it's still very
interesting to look at the
solution results that we obtain
we this formulation.
If you want to read up on this
formulation, please refer to
the study guide in which
a reference given.
A paper is referred
to in which this
formulation is described.
So let us now look at the
solution results obtained from
these three formulations.
And the solution results that
we want to look at are once
again the force displacement
curve for each of these
formulations.
In other words, force applies
here, displacement seen here,
for these three formulations.
Let's turn back to the
laboratory and see what are
the results.
Here we see the analysis results
for the MNO, that is
the materially nonlinear only,
the TL, that is the total
Lagrangian, and to UL, that
is the updated Lagrangian
formulations.
We look first at the horizontal
axis scale giving
the displacement.
And then at the vertical axis
scale giving the load that is
the pressure applied.
Notice that there are three, in
fact we will we later four
distinct curves.
However, under this much
plasticity, the curves are
almost the same.
The TL analysis results
corresponds to the smallest
displacements.
The MNO solution gives
larger displacements.
And the UL solution gives the
largest displacements.
For the UL solution, we actually
see two curves when
looking closely.
These correspond to using once
14 steps as for the TL and MNO
analyses and then using
once twice the
number of load steps.
Note that the unloading response
in all solutions is
quite the same.
However, of course, the
permanent displacements at 0
applied load are quite different
because the maximum
displacements corresponding to
peak load were different.
These analysis results underline
the importance of
choosing the appropriate
kinematic
formation for the analysis.
Here, large strain effects are
quite significant at the very
high load levels.
In the next analysis we now
consider the effect of a shaft
in the hole.
Notice, we look at the same
plate as before except that we
know first consider elastic
condition only.
And the shaft is shown here.
The shaft has this Young's
modulus and Poisson ratio,
same as the plate.
But it is 5 times thicker than
the plate and for the shaft we
also consider plane strength
conditions.
What we want to do is place a
shaft in there, the shaft
being initially flush with the
hole, assuming no friction
between the shaft
and the hole.
And then we pull on the plate
and want to investigate what
is the effect of having
that shaft there.
The analysis input data have to
now be modified because we
have to put the shaft in there
using finite elements as shown
here in red.
We used collapsed 8-node
elements to
represent the shaft.
In other words, these collapsed
8-node isoparametric
elements become, of
course, triangular
elements as shown here.
Notice we now have a contact
surface here.
And that contact surface is
modeled using a contact
algorithm, which we did
not talk about in
this series of lectures.
This again, would be best
covered in another lecture.
I'd like to refer you here to
another paper, the reference
of which is also given in the
study guide, if you're
interested in reading about
the contact algorithm.
The contact algorithm can take
into account friction
conditions as well, but in this
particular analysis, we
assume 0 friction along
the contact surface.
The solution procedure that we
are using is it the full
Newton method without
line searches.
And the convergence criteria
that we are
using are listed here.
These we have been talking
about earlier already.
Here we now because of the
contact conditions have to
introduce also this convergence
criterion, which
is really a convergence
criterion on the incremental
contact force.
So let us now proceed
with this analysis.
And once again, we perform the
analysis and of course, we're
looking at solution results.
Here we see the mesh of the
plate once more, the mesh we
used in the previous analyses.
We now need to change the input
data for the analysis to
also define the shaft.
This is done using ADINA-IN.
We need to define the addition
nodal points and elements for
the shaft in the same way as
we input earlier the nodal
points and elements
of the plate.
Let's look at the information
that defines the content
condition between the
plate and the shaft.
And here we see the input
for ADINA-IN.
There are two contact
surfaces.
The one is the plate hole
surface and the other is the
shaft surface.
We denote these two to be
a contact surface pair.
Here you now see the mesh of
the shaft and the plate.
The shaft is defined by
triangular elements.
Here we see the default
mesh at maximum load.
Note that the plate has been
extended vertically and has
shrunk horizontally.
The shaft has prevented the
hole to shrink much
horizontally.
And on top off the shaft,
a gap has opened.
All of these deformations
are quite realistic.
Here, we see just the shaft and
the ring of elements of
the plate around it.
Once again, the calculated
deformations make sense.
If you look closely at the shaft
by itself, you observe
that it has been compressed
horizontally by the plate.
Let's look next at some
stress vector plots.
These also show that a
physically realistic solution
has been obtained.
Here we see the stress vectors
in the element layer of the
plate around the shaft.
Note that the stress vectors
are plotted onto
the original mesh.
For the element adjacent to the
horizontal symmetry axis
off the plate, we see a vertical
tensile stress and a
horizontal compressive stress.
Such stresses are
to be expected.
The horizontal compressive
stress is, of course, due to
the contact with the shaft.
Note that going around the
shaft, the stresses in the
plate align to be parallel to
the free surface of the hole,
since there is only contact near
the horizontal symmetry
axis of the plate.
This completes what I wanted to
discuss with you for this
phase of the analysis.
Finally, I would like to look
with you at the analysis
results we obtained when we
apply to this plate with the
shaft 100 MPa up there
and down here.
We assume that they plate
is made of an
elasto-plastic material.
In fact, we model that
material as shown
in our early analysis.
And in addition to this loading
here shown, also the
shaft expands.
It expands uniformly.
And in fact, it expands 0.05%
based on the initial
dimensions of the shaft during
each load step and we apply 10
load steps.
So the loading then all together
is in the first load
step, 100 MPa applied here.
And from the second to 11th load
step, we expand the shaft
by 0.05% in diameter, so to
say, based on the initial
dimensions.
We use the updated Lagrangian
formulation to model the
response of the plate.
Let's look now at these
analysis results.
Here we see just as a
reminder once more
the mesh we are using.
Also, here is once more
the detail of the
mesh around the shaft.
This is the default
mesh at step 1.
The deformations are due to the
tensile load of the 100
megapascals on the plate.
Next we plot the plastic zones
in the plate as they develop
when the shaft expands.
Notice again the time code above
the mesh giving the step
number since delta t equals 1.
There are all together
11 steps.
The shaft expands from step
2 step to step 11.
We see the time code running and
at time 7 we see the first
plasticity.
This plasticity spreads as the
shaft further expands.
The maximum plastic zone is,
of course, reached at the
maximum expansion of the shaft,
that is at time 11.
This completes what I wanted
to say about this analysis.
Note that after each analysis
step we looked at the
calculated deformations and
stresses is to identify
whether these make sense.
This brings us to the end of
this lecture and to the end of
this course.
I'd like to now just take a few
minutes for some closing
remarks regarding the course.
I mentioned already in the first
lecture that nonlinear
finite element analysis
is a very large field.
There are continuum mechanics
principles, numerical
algorithms, and software
considerations.
We could not cover in detail
many aspects of all of these
fields in these 22 lectures.
However, I do believe that the
22 lectures provide a good
introduction and a good
foundation for further study.
I would hope that you would
listen to these lectures with
your colleagues, that these
lectures would initiate
discussions, stimulations for
your work in nonlinear
analysis and, of course,
also questions.
We at MIT continue to
work in nonlinear
finite element analysis.
And we also offer from time
to time weekly courses.
I would be glad to see some
off you at these weekly
courses to share some of the
experiences that you have had
listening to these video
lectures and also regarding
your work in practice.
Finally, I'd like to mention
that a video course of this
nature can only be produced
through the concerted effort
of a number of very
devoted people.
I'd like to thank for their
collaboration and support Dick
Norris, Elizabeth DeRienzo,
Pat [? Regan ?]
of the Center of Advanced
Engineering Study at MIT, and
Ted Sussman, my student.
And very finally, thanks also
for the crew around here.
Thank you for your attention.